في مصر في يوتيوبر اسمها النبويه عندها
عدد من الحسابات وقنوات يوتيوب باسم روتين
انوش ويوميات انوش وبتظهر نبويه في
الفيديوهات وهي في المطبخ وهي بتمارس
حياتها اليوميه ويعني عادي طبيعي يعني
وهنا احنا نقدر نقول لكم انه الموضوع عادي
ولكن في جدل كبير صاير حول الفيديوهات انه
شو السبب اتهام بتقديم محتوى خادش للحياه
ومخالف للاداب العامه تداول الفيديوهات
هذه خلي احد محامين حمله تطهير المجتمع
الحمل واللي اطلقها بعض ناشطه ومحامي مصر
للحفاظ على قيم المجتمع انه يعمل بلاغ
ضدها بتهمه ممارسه الفسق والفجور على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي والاعتداء على
القيم الاسريه ومن بعدها اعلنت وزاره
الداخليه القاء القبض على سيده بتهمه نشر
فيديوهات عبر المواقع الالكترونيه بتتضمن
ايماءات واشارات منافيه للا العامه ومن
بعد ما تم تحديد مكانها تم القبض عليها
ولقيو معها هاتف في فيديوهات بتاكد نشاطها
ولابتوبير وراوتر وثلاثه كروز فيزا ومعدات
تصوير واللاب توب بعد
هذا الخبر فورا الناس ربطت بيان الداخليه
باليوتيوبر النبويه او انوس ستصدر اسمها
الاخبار والعناوين مع انه ما تم ذكر اسمها
ولا حتى نشر تفاصيل سوره والشاعر من قبل
الداخليه واما التفاصيل الصادمه هياتي
رافات انوش اللي قالت انه من بعد ما ماتت
بنتها وانفصلت عن زوجها بدات تعمل محتوى
على يوتيوب عن يومياتها لكسب مال ويكون
مصدر الرزق بالنسبه لها والاولادتها ولكن
لما صار في مشاهدات على او ما صار في
مشاهدات على المحتوى استعانه باحد الاشخاص
وقت اللي بيعمل في احد قنوات يوتيوب وهو
اشار عليها انه تغير في المحتوى وتلبس لبس
فاضح عشان تجذب المشاهدات وبالفعل هذا
اللي صار وزادت مشاهداتها وصلت لما يقارب
1000 دولار اسبوعيا وقدره تشتري شقتين ومن
بعد ما عرفت طليقها وشافها لبسه الذهب
واعرف انه صار معاها فلوس طلب منها انه
يرجعوا لبعض ويرجعوا وكان هو اللي بيصورها
كمان ومن بعد هذه الاعترافات تم الحجز على
ممتلكاتها ومجوهراتها وتم موضوع حراسه
حراسه كمان على شقتين بتمتلكهم في منطقه
حلوان وقررت الداخليه تجديد حبسها اربع
ايام على ذمه التحقيق
[موسيقى]